l'action d'un jour détermine tel un
homme pour toujours c'est une question
que je me suis posée durant 78 mois eu
quelques ont fermé dans deux semaines
carré dans les prisons de notre pays
alors en action de jean taittinger
telles sommes pour toujours si on a fait
une belle action est ce que l'on est un
philanthrope pour la vie si on a fait
pour les actions est ce que l'on est un
diablotin délinquants et criminels pour
la vie cette question cela posé dans
notre métier durant 22 heures sur 24 sur
78 moi j'ai trouvé la route met d'abord
qui n'a déjà jamais entendu parler de
prison dans notre société ne serait ce
qu'au journal télévisé les candidats de
ces prisons au journal crise nous dit
bien souvent que les prisons ne
fonctionne pas nous dit bien souvent de
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a pas
assez de moyens en gérer cette mission
ces deux missions la première qui est de
mettre à l'écart les individus les plus
dangereux de notre cible la seconde de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour assurer
l'arrestation de ces individus et leur
réhabilitation sociale qu'est ce qu'on
sait de nos prisons on sait que ce que
l'on nous en dit il ya un an a été bien
trop souvent que les choses ne
fonctionnent pas et que ça coûte trop
cher et qu'il n'y a pas assez de temps
alors on va faire une petite
rétrospective sur ce que sont nos
prisons il ya bien longtemps après un
retour de voyage c'est la volée
revenus et il nous a indiqué qu'il
allait fabriquer des crises le peuple
était très content il lui a simplement
indiqué d'accord vous à les enfermer les
criminels et délinquants c'est super
mais qui va la garder
alors il les a regardés leur a dit on
trouvera certainement pire que telle
était la philosophie finalement de nos
prisons
ces prix sont chaque ciment ces prix
sont vengeance alors que l'on avait
finalement la justice pour éviter une
vengeance sociale
aujourd'hui on parle de la prison il n'y
a pas assez de places de monkeys 70
individus concernés par là qu'ils ont au
59ème place c'est à dire que la severn
on a des gens vivent à même le sol sont
dès maintenant à la même hauteur que les
reins tous les cas femme que les
punaises que la moisissure et les
champignons
est-ce que ça doit faire partie que de
se retrouver
retranché dans son humanité je ne sais
pas si ça doit faire partie mais
peut-être que ça fait partie de la
philosophie
on a parlé bien souvent pour dire que la
prison ne l'est pas assez moyen on est
presque à quasiment 3 milliards d'euros
pour 200 établissements pénitentiaires
qui doivent appliquer ce sera 10 minutes
dû surveiller pas 27 mille agents
pénitenciers pour surveiller les
individus on en soit on a 70 minutes
mais en 1 25 me jean reinhart les autres
peuples et nations vivant pour 2 3d
c'est déjà pas évident de faire son
travail quand on est nombreux à son du
côté obscur de la prison c'est à dire la
réalisation combien d'entre les agents
français font partie de cette mission de
réinsertion lundi 25 à 70 mille détenus
à savoir assurer la sécurité dans ces
établissements pénitentiaires a
contrario de l'autre côté nous avons un
peu plus de 5000 professionnels de la
réalisation pour le même nom des
personnes incarcérées
peut-on dire que mon nez sur un ratio de
1 vaut 80 90 100 120 personnes exerçant
avec il va falloir créer un projet de
rénovation réaliste et elsa
je suis venu vous parler de la prison
parce que la prison est une véritable
question de société et en france cela ne
concerne pas que le voisin d'à côté une
limite en face à ces 70 personnes ont
reçu une famille en tout six victimes
ces victimes ont aussi eu du fun et pour
traiter poussera il nous a fallu mettre
en herbe organisé les jeux justice et
non là on a des magistrats qui sont en
charge le suivi de toutes ces affaires
est de pouvoir garantir la sécurité de
notre set on ne propose bien souvent l'a
déjà entendu parler et dire il faut
donner aux gens une deuxième chance mais
pour autant il ne retient fallu déjà usé
la première chance
combien de gens dans notre pays à qui on
dit nul n'est censé ignorer la loi
je ne crois pas dit si nous soyons tous
nés bien coiffée il ya des gens qui sont
nés bien causer qui autour autour d'eux
pour comprendre les enjeux de notices et
l'école rebelles
comment se comporter comment ne pas
dépasser 6 bennett pour respecter celui
d'autres il ya des gens qui disent cela
c'est une facilement sans cible facile
qui pourra à la nôtre pas un autre
itinéraire via les choses ne s'inquiète
pas aussi facilement que pour les autres
mais pour autant c'est la même règle
pour tous c'est tant mieux iman mois et
les bretons quels moyens comme à nos
enfants et à nos populations de
comprendre le sont pas et de défendre
alors la prison est ce que là qu'ils ont
dit at milan en accrocher les gens dans
des cases en bois et on était dans des
âmes ce parti se fasse manger par d
autres s contre milan nous n'avons pu
faire que défendre les cages au sein il
fait en sorte que je ne soit qu'une des
oiseaux des rats qui concerne nos
garçons gasser donc je pense qu'on est
dans une société où l'on vend mieux que
l'enfermement seulement la prison a été
aujourd'hui réfléchi en termes d'
enfermement donné zalika d'exclusion
la prison est un système d'exclusion est
un système de vengeance est un système
qui finalement un favorise la vengeance
sociale
on a une dans une grande école j'ai
passé soixante dix huit mois n'a pas
mâché ses hommes s'étaient pas dakota
écoles des commerces
c'était la beauté comme des criminalités
je suis en prison oui bien sûr vous
rentrez pas ce que nous avait volé une
barre de chocolat vous ressortez capable
de braquer un brics nous eh bien pas te
faire tout ce que nous ne peut pas
proposer de faire dans cette cour de
promenade dans cette éminente à
l'enfermement aujourd'hui en france
représente la peine or il me semble est
pas parce que je suis un ancien détenu
nous naissons quels enseignements peut
faire partie de l'équation
c'est vrai mais ne doit pas représenter
l'émotion j'avais région explique
l'enfermement doit faire partie de la
tête c'est qu'il nous c'est un
conditionnement mais pour quoi faire
est ce que c'est pour eux l'expliquent
cpj est ce que c'est pour eux qu'ils
soient gentils qui sera belle de la
douleur ou de ceux qu'il a cassé dans la
vie de notre ville qui balisent ou est
ce que c'est pour conscientiser l'acte
qui va causer comprendre ce qu'il a fait
à cerner et comprendre les mécanismes et
les ressources qu'ils désirent organiser
au 6 août
les 6-7 ans s'associe une notion
extrêmement importante de se dire
comment est ce même individu ou échanger
et à quel point nous pouvons faire
ensemble que l'enfermement puisse l'y
aider incarcéré à l'individu bien sûr
que c'est montrer à chacun sa faute et a
fauté cas pas respectés alors que les
jets ont préféré plutôt le terme de
sanction ce que dans les termes de
sanction il ya une connotation positive
certainement que la majorité d'entre
vous ont déjà été sanctionnés
on n'est pas puni d'un diplôme et donc
donner du sens à la prison c'est donner
du sens à la justice et que les licences
à la justice et donner du sens à la
citoyenneté
chaque individu doit notifier ci a pas
de justice à voit qu'on est impossible
c'est aussi cette mécanique il faut
pouvoir essayer d'injecter chez un
certain nombre de
la défense de nos populations qui n'ont
fait lui même une chance alors il n'y a
pas de déterminisme
il n'y a pas de fatalisme son niveau du
dos disposez vous dire que ma mission
immigration qu'on a décrit grotte dans
la quartier populaire rio les terres de
la ville et conçoivent une vocation du
nord et bien un passage en prison n'est
pas obligatoire le passage du chômage
n'est pas obligatoire mais pour autant
elle va falloir investir autrement
qu'ils sont les carences d'un individu
devons regarder au travers de vos
carences c'est parce qu'il vous fera
rayonner le plus vous regarder au
travers de votre potentiel
c'est quelque chose qui peut ramener ces
échanges et le développement
lang d'agir chez un individu et
finalement c'est peut-être ça qui
forcera les changements puisque les
regards noirs portés sur lui même à
présenter au parc de la peine de prison
on m'avait dit dans nos box dans cette
courte à signer ce que nos amis disant
d'église indigne de l'homme a dit enfin
l'or pourrait ainsi pour ne pas
recommencer
et puis je suis allé dans une prison où
j'ai dû me dernier devant un inconnu
comme si ça c'est parti n'était et puis
finalement j'ai dû faire des listes
d'attentes depuis six mois d'attentes
pour avoir accès à une
nation professionnels qualifie comme si
la formation ne représentait pas un
levier pour la réinsertion d'amour en
indemnisant de bord et quand je parle de
pauvreté qui parle pas de cordes
essentiellement économique
je bats aussi et surtout de pauvreté
sociale psychologique scolaire et
familial des gens qui arrivent
complètement cassée par la victime d'un
schéma familial qu'elle y sommes et qui
se trouve complètement en déshérence
dans une société qui n'a pas le temps
d'attendre les plus fragiles les plus
vils d'accord entre eux alors oui un
portable handicap ont marqué que celui
de l'inde invitée dans la vie il ya des
handicaps scission sentir de crise ont
cette année cinq véritablement savez
aujourd'hui je croise plein de jeunes
dans des quartiers ailleurs dans des
zones à risque
les jeux sont enfermés dans les grandes
marques telles que ses jeunes clients
certains me disent tu n'es même pas plus
aplatie
il n'est dit ça à moi alors que la seule
grande bugée dans toute ma vie ça a été
cette sortie de prison
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la prison
ne fait plus peur
par contre peut revenir dans la société
ça fait extrêmement parce que on sait
que les individus qui sortent le grison
sans projet professionnel réaliste et
réalisable monté pendant l'intérieur des
murs n'ont aucune chance de vingt
logements des 60 cents d'entre vous
récidivez entre trois et cinq ans plus
tard notre finalement qu'est-ce qu'on
peut se dire sur la prison alors bien
sûr ça fonctionne ça fonctionne comme
l'histoire l'a dit que non d'ailleurs la
france chaque année est condamnée par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme à
payer des amendes à verser des amendes
qui coûte bien plus cher que l'ensemble
des changements entre rembrandt de
l'échangé efficace possible céderons pas
une histoire d'argent il me semble que
c'est une histoire comme philosophie
châtiment est ce que l'on veut des
prisons ici dans les têtes des individus
se confondent avec les flux des gens qui
entrent et qui sortent de manière
intemporelle
il n'existe plus ce sont juste des
chiffres dans des bases de données
est ce que l'on pourrait faire le pari
de passer d'une crise on usine à une
prison de karaj cette prison qui
amènerait cette notion de réparation
parce qu'il en était toute l'école au
défi d'essayer de saint mandé dans un
espace 2
j'aurais rêvé tout le monde ici au défi
de pouvoir montrer le meilleur de soi
même dans une cache de 9 m² j'aimerais
encore mais si vous me permettez tout le
monde ici au défi d'essayer de réparer
ce qui est cassé
alors c'est impossible vous pouvez
retourner donc laissons ça n'existe pas
il n'y a pas de notion de réparation et
pour tous deux viennent
j'ai senti le 27 septembre 2002 et
depuis cette date je ne fais que faire
ma tête parce que lorsque j'étais en
prison aujourd'hui en tant
qu'intervenant et je rencontre ces
individus incarcérés essaye de trouver
le chemin dans la city mais pour tous
les gars qui sont les leurs n'y arrive
pas dans tous les cas que l'on pose sur
eux c'est pour nous eh bah oui quand je
n'en mangerai qui a été le mien j'ai
l'association de mamans des plus peut-on
b92 lorsque je vais dans une école
comment votre et que mon essai échanges
autour
si tu étais la prison parce que quelle
que soit la couleur la prison restera
très grands efforts de nos dossiers et
ben oui j'ai la sensation de mal en pis
et pareillement lorsque je vais dans un
quartier où le calme de la ville en
vente et les jeunes avec un moule et des
bonbonnes de cocaïne
je viens de parler du service' service
civique à l'engagement l'intérêt général
pour un jeune de six 6 mois et j'essaie
de les engager son chemin
c'est ainsi qu'est née l'association de
réparer alors est ce que en enfermant
seulement on n'enferme pas seulement les
ingrédients d'ailleurs des petits sont
ses bras les prisons c'est pas juste des
murs des bars et des grilles à ceux ci
les hommes des femmes et des enfants
ils sont en france et ont enfermé à vie
recule l'âge de 13 ans dans des
établissements pénitentiaires pour nous
donc il ya des enfants de 13 ans qui
sont en crise c'est d'abord les mains
plus que le béton et la ferme et les
caméras et les grillages
c'est d'abord des êtres humains qui ont
triché
ou deux jours à 10 h au parc ou par
nécessité et qui n'achetaient la pierre
à personne commence à les jeter aussi
important d'être dans une société avec
de l'empathie l'empathie saint menges
dire on recense que 60 cm où on explique
aux en excuses il faut comprendre ce que
l'on dit pourquoi les skis réagi comme
ça ça tunisien et somment de se lever le
matin d'aller commettre un délit
il se retrouve privé de sa liberté parce
que normalement la présence à 10 ans
sont patine c'est l'activation d'aller
et de venir
pourtant on se rend compte que le bar la
purée c'est fou comme on se retrouve
humilié à focaliser déresponsabiliser
déshumanisé est ce que ce sera bon côté
pour favoriser la réinsertion la bonne
intégration dans l'intimité dorothy si
j'en crois pas mais c'est pourquoi le
ton décisive est extrêmement fort c'est
clair le port de la castration n'est pas
mis à profit
autant pour l'individu que pour la
diététique l'autre alors à ses dunes
qu'ils ont une haine qu'ils ont diaz
voudrait dire un délai mission de
réparer qu'un seul individu il faut
qu'il ait les mains des dégâts qu'ils
ont causés par ces quais et qui n'est
pas réparable mon cas j'ai pas drôle et
une poubelle je n'ai pas volé
voiture j'aime participer à la mort d'un
homme comme en espérant par n'y a pas
d'équivalence alors peut-être main en
insufflant la notion de responsabilité
chez les individus alors mes enfants
sera certainement le développement de
change normalement on peut faire partie
de la peine pour du camp ni même des
regard pluridisciplinaire avec des
professionnels qui ne s'improvise pas
expert et lors qu'il ya de l'actualité
des gens qui ont véritablement aubrac au
graal qu une envie d'agir envers les
populations et les chanteuses étaient
les plus en difficulté et la prison est
une institution qui est un service
public est une extension de notre
système judiciaire et pénal
il n'est pas question de voile à se
fabriquer dans cette prison
la récidive voir c'est favoriser la
radicalisation religieuse et violente
on m'a bien entendu paris qui fait qu'un
peur tout le monde et qui terrorise et
bien gardés en de terroriser parce que
c'est l'europe a raté les as anglais
pourquoi est ce que l'on se radicalise
serait plus dans des zones de notre
société comme les prisons qu'ailleurs
c'est peut-être dans ses dix ans plus
qu'ailleurs il ya
nous allons certainement en créant de la
proximité entre le dedans et le dehors
la maison étape
les deux fermiers c'est presque un état
dans l'état on ne vous en dira que ce
qu'on voudra alors créer de la proximité
c'est pas juste dire amener un député
avec trois journalistes
ça peut aussi vouloir dire qu'on peut
aller apprendre à ces individus-là
cassel comment créer une entreprise
comment se réinsérer au travers des
qualités des compétences les uns des
temps ci sont les biens les aider à se
rappeler qu'ils étaient avant de passer
à l'acte les aider à mieux comprendre
pourquoi notre cd n'a pas accepté là
qu'ils sont posées et à quel point il
faut absolument évoluer lui faire
comprendre si tu es finalement il va
ressortir qu'il soit condamné pour des
faits de droits communs ou quand même
pour des faits relatifs en théorie car
en france on a aboli la peine de mort il
ya pas longtemps à ce que l'on ne
pouvait plus être des assassins même
face à des associations alors comment
allons-nous réactionnaire ces individus
avec la gueule au ventre qu'est-ce qu'on
aura alors proposé ces individus les
plus radicalisés lorsque vous tous ici
nous de les lâcher ce qui vous tirent le
plus d'ancienneté
les bulles on vous propose rien d'autre
qu elle vous raconte
allez vous
il est tombé tout ce pour quoi vous
pourriez même si ces idées sont aussi
motivés alors à ces individus je ne
viens pas leur raconter quelque chose il
va leur donner à contrôler dispo en rien
leur donner la possibilité de comprendre
qu'il ya un contre projet contre projet
de vie ça mène à la distance n'a
d'existence ramène même au bien-être
personnel au service du collectif
donc la prison elle peut être un outil
l'impulsion et sociales et non pas
d'exclusion sociale
mais pour faire un médiateur a vraiment
dit m et pour terminer
terminé on vous dira que au travers de
mon parcours il a fallu cours à
bologhine j'ai aujourd'hui la
reconnaissance riche peut avoir
aujourd'hui il a fallu convaincre par
l'exemple que l'on vienne le terme aux
chances que je vous fais même réintégrer
cette société pourquoi pas même en plus
value mais pourquoi c'était une
normalité petit moment pour la société
parce que j'ai passé à tanger j'ai passé
ma victoire
gales j'ai des yeux un cerveau est un
tueur comme alors à ce titre j'ai aussi
le droit de porter des idées
cauval par exemple c'est une chose et
s'échanger les prisons de notre société
en est une autre
effectivement ça représente peut-être un
idéal de changer les prisons de
motricité bien eu des avancées je les
attends plusieurs fois dans sa peau
d'une femme a des relations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]